Wall Street ended another tumultuous
week with another big loss on Friday the
Dow fell more than 900 points but the
week also saw the biggest one-day point
gain in history following word that a
two trillion dollar economic relief
package would pass Congress the
coronavirus aid relief and Economic
Security Act or cares was signed into
law by President Trump on Friday joining
us to talk about what is in the package
and how it may affect you is CBS news
senior business analyst Jill Schlesinger
Jill let's start right there how is this
bill going to affect Americans what are
the big takeaways I think the big
takeaways is that that we really are
seeing a lifeline come from Washington
DC we've got three aspects big aspects
of the plan and we think about
individuals first well you mentioned
earlier in the show those checks $1,200
checks to anyone who makes less than
$75,000 that amount does faze lower as
you approach $99,000 just know that if
you make less than 99 thousand dollars
as a household your adjusted gross
income you're going to get a check
there's also another $500 per child very
helpful again have to be part of that
income but for individuals the biggest
aspect to me is the expanding of the
unemployment benefits so the government
is tacking on 13 weeks to whatever the
maximum is in your state and also
providing a check of $600 a week on top
of whatever your state unemployment
benefit is so that's for the individuals
there's relief for small businesses and
corporations I think the small business
part is really important there are loans
that are available to cover your payroll
your rent your utilities and those loans
from the SBA through the Small Business
Administration would be forgiven as long
as you have the same amount of money
going out towards payroll that you for
the next eight weeks that you did in the
prior run up to the virus so when do
people get these checks and how well you
know it's going to be really interesting
from the checks the direct payments if
you have a record on file with the
government of a direct deposit so maybe
you're a Social Security recipient
maybe you filed your taxes
electronically that's going to be the
way you get your money it'll be a few
weeks but if for some reason you still
get paper checks this could take up to
two three some people who take even four
months simply because the government
doesn't have the facility to print
checks and this couldn't hold you up
unemployment benefits should be coming
pretty quickly after you apply state
systems got clogged up but we're hearing
two to three weeks is when the
unemployment benefits should be received
so we've talked about this economy
feeling like it just came to a
standstill as we're starting to feel
some of the impact can you look ahead a
few months to have any indication as to
how much worse it may get well I think
that we're at the tip here and we're
clearly in a recession we had the IMF
chief say that the world is already in a
recession many of the economists I speak
to say that this is at least sort of a
march through the summer event so we're
going to see a recession which is
loosely defined as two negative quarters
in a row but I think that we're going to
see the economy really come to a halt
right now slowly start to begin to
unwind a little bit and then hopefully
by the time at the end of the summer
into the end of the year we should come
back and I put an asterisk on that that
is predicated say economists on the fact
that the virus is contained they worried
that if we reopen too quickly we dip
down again and that's why they're
watching very closely what a lot of
these governors are doing that's the big
question Jill about whether this is a
v-shaped recovery or a W and that is
whether you sink down and come right
back up or or dip along a little bit and
continue to have trouble right I think
that the the first part of this when we
first were hearing about it everybody
did talk about that nice big V then we
started in the middle of it and we say
oh gosh maybe it's an L like you just go
down and muddle along the bottom but I
think that we're sort of looking at
probably a you and hopefully that means
that we sort of bounce around the bottom
and then come back up the W which was a
double-dip recession meaning we seem to
be better things open up again but
the virus continues to spread and then
people freaked out that's what we would
like to avoid one big plug here if
you're a small business go to sba.gov
there's great information on there how
you can access those loan programs
always a good idea to support small
business Jill thank you very much